ladies and gentlemen welcome to 221c
baker street home of the 10 million
dollar
studio i'm your host coffee zilla
and today we are exposing
and coming clean on exactly what the 10
million dollar studio
is who made it everything about it guys
i i really
felt and sorry for the long intro by the
way because this may be the last time
you look at the 10 million dollar studio
with your naive eyes
with the eyes that don't know the full
story i wanted to come clean guys
because
on this show i talk a lot about fakes
talk a lot about fakers
liars cheaters people who aren't telling
you the full truth who are
withholding the truth from you and one
of the things i say is like look you can
never believe what people tell you
uh the truth is guys
i don't think i'd be talking about this
well why don't i show you
the truth is it's been a green screen
all along
or has it see that's what many of you
have believed
for a very long time and i've been
purposely avoiding
the question because i didn't think you
guys were ready for
the truth that ends today all this
chicanery all these lies end
today see the studio you've been seeing
this whole time
is neither real nor is it fake
it was a fake of the real
look this is the real
10 million dollar studio
and i know what you're saying that looks
exactly like
the 10 million dollar studio but what
happened was i've been
faking a real studio
while actually being inside of the real
studio
see i put a green screen right behind me
in this room
right where we sit right now and then i
projected the exact same room
why would i do that to create a little
green spill
guys green spill is the telltale sign
of a fake set but the truth was it was
all a facade to throw off the people who
want to know my next
move and i don't want them to know but
in the process of throwing them off my
sin
i lied to you guys and i'm finally ready
to come clean about it
see the truth is it was never a green
screen
green tape right here um it was always
real this is proof right here if
it was a green screen this wouldn't this
wouldn't exist
and i know what you're thinking maybe
that's a fake object maybe you cgi'd
that in
right maybe that's what you're thinking
to yourself you think it's steven you
cgied that in
incorrect since i'm always telling
people not to trust anybody i thought i
might as well come clean about this too
so uh yeah what i have what i have on
under here is a green
shirt and now many of you are thinking
oh that's clever
steven you just got yourself a blue
screen many of you know that there's
also
a blue screen available and you're like
well you faked the green screen then you
painted your wall blue
but that too is incorrect
see i thought of everything to prove
myself to you guys
here today and i just figured the only
way i could is just with complete
transparency
and honesty see the truth is guys i
really do have
the 10 million dollar studio it's all
real
i was just faking it for a while in
order to throw people off my
scent i didn't want them to fully
understand
uh what we had going on here but on this
most auspicious of days
i'm finally ready to come clean i've
just been bamboozling you guys the whole
time
lying to you guys a ruse within a ruse
okay
so um i'm sorry about that i hope i can
earn back your trust
and to all of you who've been wondering
how i do such incredible virtual
production
it's just because it's easier to be real
you know it's easier to not fake this
kind of stuff you think i'd fake this
no so guys don't forget to pump the
stock
zilla is going to the moon this year but
it's just not on a green screen
thank you for watching i appreciate you
and i'll see you next time